the common view at the time was that if
you take plants that have two different
characters what you will get in the
hybrid is sort of a blended average of
the two characteristics so if you had a
tall plant in a short plant you'd get an
intermediate sized plant that is not
what Mendel observed he observed instead
that all of the plants in the hybrid
cross were actually tall and that told
him something very important which is
that the tall character prevailed and
the short character
wherever that came from had disappeared
completely and so the question that
Mendel might have asked at that point is
whether the character that determines
shortness in a plant had completely
disappeared so he did the next really
critical experiment which is he allowed
those tall plants to self fertilize
themselves and he asked what are the
seeds look like from the progeny of that
cross and the answer was three of the
progeny are tall and one of the progeny
is short so in that original tall plant
in the in the first generation the short
character had not been destroyed it had
not completely disappeared into the
ozone it had been dominated by the
character tall and in fact Mendel used
that word he said tall is dominant over
short and the word he used to describe
short is recessive and what's really
remarkable is to this day we use these
terms to describe the behavior of genes
in crosses
which is amazing to me
[Music]
you